your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV hello I'm Douglas Murray and welcome
to uncensored tonight the latest
champion for UK women to the UN is
you've guessed it a biologically born
male women's groups are outraged but
should they be we'll debate
and after Harvard's first black
president is forced to resign over
allegations of anti-Semitism and
plagiarism we'll ask if Merit needs to
matter more than box ticking
diversity and I'm joined by one of the
world's leading personal growth gurus
Chris Williamson from the modern wisdom
podcast he'll be talking with me about
whether New Year New You commitments are
just so much
nonsense
live from the news building in London
this is Pier Morgan
uncensored welcome to Pier Morgan
uncensored where it's day two of me
Douglas Murray filling in for the great
man uh I'm standing in for peers because
he's claiming he can't get into work and
that's well it's because of the weather
yes it's just far too sunny in Beverly
Hills to leave so soon after Christmas
here's another peer post from yesterday
by the way where he seems to be reading
Arnold Schwarzenegger's new book a
reminder if not a subtle warning to us
all that he'll be
back this week we're looking at the big
themes which will dominate the global
agenda in 2024 but what I didn't think
would be on that list was the subject of
darts that's all thanks to 16-year-old
Luke ller who has reached the final of
tonight's World Championships which you
can see see and hear live on our sister
Channel talk sport now people are saying
little Luke looks a lot older than his
years but I think that's unfair after
all if we're willing to accept
middle-aged men arriving on small boats
self-identifying as teenage poys and why
shouldn't we question or not question
rather a homegrown darts Prodigy besides
we can't all have the youthful Visage of
a cherubic angel uh like young Pierce
Morgan or is that his prettiest sister
anyhow talking of gender confusion this
story has also caught my eye today meet
Monroe Bergdorf a model who has been
controversially appointed the UK
champion at un women a charity that
seeks to improve the lives of women and
girls and promote equality within Civil
Society the corporate sector and
government well it's controversial
because Monroe was to put it in the
modern Parliament a signed male at birth
or born of bloke as others might put it
17 women's rights groups have signed a
letter to the charity complaining about
a transgender woman representing them on
the committee especially since part of
their written objection is that Monroe
has in the past objected to women making
references to our female bodies although
Monroe did once set up a nightclub
called the Palace so empowering
don't you think it was Groucho Marx who
said I don't want to belong to a club
that would have me as a member well I'm
not sure any woman should want to belong
to a group that would have Monroe bured
off as their Champion but there's
another good reason all women should rip
up their membership of this group in my
humble opinion take a look at their
reaction to the revelations of sexual
violence by Hamas in October is there a
reason though Sarah that you can't
specifically call out Hamas you and
women always supports partial
independent investigations into any
serious allegations of gender-based or
sexual violence and within the UN family
these investigations are led by the
office of the High Commissioner of Human
Rights it took the group a full 57 days
after the Hamas attack to make any
official statement and even then that
was to condemn gender-based atrocities
or mass rape as the rest of us call it
seems to me that this group really has a
problem with language and also with
reality so Monroe Bergdorf and the UN
women's group probably deserve each
other here to debate here in the studio
in London our talk TV contributors
Esther kru and Paula Ron Adrian thanks
so much for being with you both tonight
um what do you make of this story let's
start with you Ester it just seems
amazing to me that of the 33 million or
so women in the UK
a biological male is is their choice
that's quite an interesting you know I
always think what would happen if we
ignored people that are trying to force
their reality onto us because I don't
believe we have an obligation to
validate falsehoods and delusions
certainly the law doesn't public policy
doesn't and I don't think individuals in
a country that lives with as we say we
have free speech I don't think we have
to either um but this Insidious drive
now has infiltrated so many aspects of
society I think on the one hand I
personally can canot be bothered to
constantly be outraged by this because I
know there are some people that will
never have their minds changed which is
fine but on the other hand if we ignore
it what will happen in the future how
will our children be raised how how will
we be able to tackle it if it becomes
like a seems like a cancer that will
never go away that's the bigger problem
I have here clearly Monroe buged off you
know this person is very famous in the
UK and this a trans transwoman that's a
biological man that has believes that
they were born in the wrong body that's
fine but you're insulting women
effectively by saying this is the only
person that can represent women 33 women
33 million women in the UK what do you
think about that Paul I think they're
not saying that she's the only one but
she's the one they've chosen of the 33
million that that does seem slightly
jarring doesn't it uh no so my position
is of course that the right person is
chosen for the job um and if the right
person is uh Monroe then Monroe is the
right person I I'm not fearful or don't
feel challenged or don't feel that I'm
in competition with with Monroe let me
just make it clear I don't know who
Monroe um is personally I've only read
about her um I read the letter that was
written to the um un uh uh women's group
UK group um and what I understood from
the letter the concerns were twofold the
first was that Monroe was not pro women
and the second was that Monroe had
written a number of historical tweets um
that were racist and that were
homophobic now for both of those reasons
if they're right then I would agree
because clearly then Monroe would not be
let's just let's just remind ourselves
of exactly what it is because if you're
choosing anyone as a diplomat a
representative of an organization I mean
you wouldn't want somebody who for
instance said in called called somebody
on Twitter in 2012 a hairy Baron lesbian
said she wanted a gay Basher TV star and
called the suffragettes white
supremacist I mean it's not it's not the
best out Outreach thing is it I mean no
but can I can I just say when we talk
about outrage and when we talk about a
cancer I believe that the outrage and
the cancer is somewhat um somewhat
misguided let me explain to you why I'm
intrigued that we continue to talk about
trans women I mean why do you think it
is well I tell you why it is is because
there are certain groups in society that
are happy for what are two marginalized
groups to infight okay and let me you
why because if if this amount of energy
was ex expended on why it is we still
have a gender pay gap of
14.3% if this energy was expended on why
it is that professional sports women are
not being CED for in the same way in
terms of their commercial contracts uh
why it is that they get beaten up by by
by less is that Serena
and same am that's a disingenuous
argument as they were for that's a dis
argument then I would kind of understand
these allies you're pretending you're
pretending not to know why there is a
reason why there's a reason why we're
fixated more on the issues to do with
trans women than trans men because you
don't have sporting organizations
validating trans men in male Sports
because it doesn't exist right there's a
reason why we there's there's all this
sort of controversy around trans women
in female prisons because it doesn't
happen the other way around that is the
reason why and to pretend or to just
suppose that against other legitimate
issues is completely disingenuous you
know why this person Monroe burdov who
was born with a penis cannot represent
women in this country because this
person will never understand
gender-based violence because this is a
biological man they will never
understand how it feels as a woman to
have a biological man in your toilet
because they're a man by the way I agree
I agree with both of you a bit and I
certainly agree with you Paul and I
would rather never talk about these
issues ever again but unfortunately as
we all know they keep coming forward
because I mean kind of deliberately
provocative things like CH choosing a
biologically born man as a woman's
representative just comes up I I'm going
to bring in though we've got coming from
Nashville Tommy larren is from the Tommy
lren is fearless uh uh podcast thanks so
much for joining us Tommy what do you
make of all
this well listen I think we need to
start calling this what it is this is an
absolute slap in the face to actual
women and I refuse to use the term
biological women I refuse to refer to
myself as a biological woman I am not a
woman I'm not cisgender I'm not any of
these other things I am a woman and I
thought that the feminist movement was
cultivated to stand by women real women
and female empowerment and women's
rights and our spaces and our sports but
unfortunately that movement has been
hijacked by what I call the Rainbow
Mafia and now this whole trans movement
has decided that their one goal not
about making equality for Trans people
or awareness for Trans people has been
about overtaking women's Sports women's
spaces women's rights and the fact that
there are now certain activists that
have completely abandoned what should be
the actual feminist movement in favor of
this rainbow Mafia to me is laughable
and if they're going to call me
transphobic for saying that in the words
of our swimmer Riley Gaines I would say
well then I guess that makes you a
misogynist we're not using these terms
these labels these definitions anymore
we're going to call things like they are
we're going to speak with science at the
Forefront and we're not going to play
these games anymore at least here in the
United States well whil I've got you
there in the United States it does seem
the United States is sort of Ground Zero
for a lot of this stuff and I wanted to
take us on to another story because
California I know you're in in Nashville
Tennessee a very sensible state I'm sure
but over in the slightly crazier State
of California uh a new law has come in I
couldn't quite believe this when I read
this a new Law's come in saying that all
large to toy retailers in California
have to have quote gender neutral toy
aisles and apparently this is because uh
uh uh instead of having a sort of clear
aisle for boys toys and a clear aisle
for girls toys that's a bit too um it's
a bit too uh I don't know it's a bit too
obvious it's a bit too uh well the 20th
century and every Century before that um
and and so apparently now you know sort
of children and their parents should be
able to sort of skip around the aisles
and choose whatever toy is most suitable
for their gender identity what do you
make of this law and law it
is well I'll tell you I did live in Los
Angeles for 3 years before I fled to
Nashville Tennessee and I'll tell you
there's a lot of problems in California
homelessness taxes regulations illegal
immigration drug use open air drug
markets filth on the streets human feces
on the streets needles on the streets
and I would think that gender neutral
toy aisles would end on the last of list
of priorities for governor Nome and the
rest of the Democrats that control that
state but alas we we've discovered that
that is their priority finding retailers
that have already been through enough
with the co lockdowns and shutdowns
finally regaining their ground after
that time also inflicted on them by
Democrat politicians and now they're
going to be fined if they don't have
gender neutral toy sections I'd also
remind people that in California because
they're felon coddling laws and policies
you can actually steal $450 more than
these retailers would be finded and that
would be considered a misdemeanor so
let's just put that in perspec yes I you
can shoplift and that's essentially the
same thing as a toy aisle that's not
gender neutral that's California
priorities for you I don't know why
everybody hasn't fled that state thank
you Tommy um I I've got to bring that
back to the studio uh Paul Ness I think
the idea here is that we shouldn't
impose uh gender identity performativity
I think is one of the one of the one of
the bizarre terms that it's used uh but
here's something that slightly subverts
that argument um there's a study that
just came out the most most popular uh
toys for girls on Amazon jewelry box
princess castle and karaoke microphone
and you don't need to guess which sex
these are the most popular toys for on
Amazon stunt car dboard walkie-talkies
and toy soldier Army swap helmet I think
the point is and it's a shame that they
had to bring in a law uh but I think the
point is is that it's okay if your son
wants a pram and if your son points to a
pram uh on the Shelf buy your son a pram
it's no big deal if your son very
generous if your son wants to dress up
as a um Disney princess and says I want
to dress up as a Disney princess let
your son dress up as a Disney princess
if your daughter conversely wants to
wants to get a toy soldier Army SWAT
helmet exactly absolutely it's no big
deal well the thing is I think that's a
very generous assessment because these
kinds of people are known for thinking
that everything has somehow been is a
result of social conditioning so I don't
think they're mandating this because
they say it's okay if your son wants to
wear a dress not in my house but okay um
it's the point that they they actually
think they actually think it's okay if
your wears a dress it will be fine but
they actually think young people are
socially conditioned to this even though
it goes against all the scientific data
on this the reality is men like well
boys like things girls like people and
that's just that's just the reality of
how we're genetically predisposed and
that you say that that that you think or
that you think that people are
suggesting that their social condition
in the same way that you think that
somehow your son
will not happening in my house if he
wears a dress it's just not happening in
my house well that's kind of clear I'd
like to thank both my guests in the
studio thank you Esther and Paul and
thanks very much Tommy for joining us
all the way over in Nashville Tennessee
now up next on uncensored after the
resignation of Harvard University's
first black president I'll be talking to
Ayan her Al who says it's time for the
whole diversity equity equity and
inclusion agenda to be kicked out of
major institutions once and for
[Music]
all we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online we on your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about sport today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell is winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this gu shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
Phil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party
hi kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve
this is really unfair what what what's
unfair if it's on camera we're not doing
the interviews yes I'm going to do
you're going to Res yes course I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very very telling talk TV it's
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to uncensored with me
Douglas Murray standing in for Piers
Morgan reaction to the resignation of
the president of Harvard Claudine gay
has been predictably divided for some
the University's first blackhe head
deserved to lose her job after
accusations of plagiarism and a
completely shambolic performance at a
congressional hearing on anti-Semitism
last
month and Dr Gay at Harvard does calling
for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as at an individual it's
targeted at Jewish students Jewish
individuals so the answer is yes that
calling for the genocide of Jews
violates Harvard code of conduct
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign amazing all depends on the
context apparently anyway some people
are ignoring that and are claiming that
there's actually a Sinister racial
agenda in this
sacking the uh civil rights activist
Reverend Al Sharpton said that Gay's
resignation is quote an assault on the
health strength and future of diversity
equity and inclusion well my next guest
has done a lot of thinking about this
subject and she says it's time to make
Merit matter more than liberal box
ticking delighted to welcome to
uncensored research fellow at Stanford's
Hoover Institute the author and activist
Ayan heri Ayan her Al thanks so much for
joining us on
uncensored tell me oh Douglas thank you
for having me tell me first of all what
what do you make of the Reverend Al
Sharpton's claim there this is all about
race
apparently it's not all about race it's
about the mediocrity Mafia that he
represents so well and that he has
profited from for so many years and I
think it's time that we ditch this
diversity equity and inclusion uh
movement that is really all about
dismantling and degrading our
institutions they're about expanding our
history and they're about indoctrinating
kids at school and it starts at
universities and it goes beyond that and
I'm really one of those people today who
is celebrating the uh resignation of
Claudia being gay but I think I'm also
realistic enough to say that is just at
the surface the problem is much deeper
it started at universities it has spread
to corporations it has spread to uh
lower Ed you know from K to 12 it's
everywhere in America and I think it's
time that we take a good look a good
deep look at what's going on and this is
just the start I agree with you I I mean
this this is why it matters you know
sometimes people think that what happens
at Harvard is just a bit of ivy League
stuff but it isn't as you say because
it's it's going out all across the rest
of America indeed the rest of the world
I mean well the rest of the West anyway
plenty of people in China are getting on
with things anyway but um just just
going back quickly to Claudine gate
Harvard I mean I find it pretty
startling that this is a woman who
became president of perhaps the most
elite University in America and she's
she published no books she published 11
articles in her career and it's turned
out that uh much of them were just
plagiarized stolen from other people so
how did she even get there in the first
place she has 50 allegations of
plagiarism against her Douglas my
grandmother would not trust claan gay to
her her goats she this woman could not
be the president of Harvard I don't
understand how this happened and yet I
do and people like me you know Helen
plos James Lindsay um there were so many
of us Al who saw this years and years
ago and who kept on saying this thing is
rotten it's not going to go away we were
told so many times oh it's universities
you know radical ideas emerge in
universities but over time they
disappear no the rot is deep and this
woman one small representative of it
she's gone and my big worry Douglas now
is that they're going to say okay this
woman is gone the one p uh University is
gone and you know we're going to have a
new president we're going to maybe have
a new board and move on and I think that
would be such a squandering of
opportunity for real reform let me give
you another couple of reactions uh to
her resignation uh this week Ibraham X
kendi the author of a book called How To
Be An anti-racist which I think the
wrong title for it you should just take
anti out um Ibraham X kendi said that in
the wake of claudian Gay's resignation
uh racist mobs won't stop until they
topple all black people from positions
of power and influence and Ida Bay Wells
Nicole Hannah Jones uh one of the
authors of the 1619 project for the New
York Times said after the resignation
academic freedom is under attack racial
Justice programs are under attack black
women will be made to pay I mean there
are still people Clinging On to this
aren't there Ayan this sort of um
somebody must be defended simply on the
color of their skin and all the claims
of plagiarism which would get any
student chucked out and all the in
ability to condemn racism which would
normally lead to condemnation all that
sort of brushed to one side CU what
really matters is just the color of
somebody's skin to these people Abraham
X kendi is a racist he is a certified
racist everything all the work he has
done all his actions are about promoting
racism and so this man is being oued
what he stands for is being exposed and
I think what's happening now is because
of this exposure the kind of um they
have this magical um I'm looking for the
word the spell that they've been putting
on people just by calling them places
they would get what they want out of
them they would get the positions the
Stag the money I think all of that's
going to disappear so they are now
coming out in panic and saying oh my
goodness everybody is a racist black
people wellbe no black people will
benefit from this finally those
individuals who are black who have
worked hard for their degrees and the
positions they have and their businesses
those people are going to shine
and these like Mafia mediocre Mafia
people they're going to be exposed and
hopefully be taken to where they belong
which is the Des spin of history now um
couldn't agree more but Ayan just tell
me I mean it's it's it's it's so much
wider this for the whole of society
isn't it because I mean once once these
ideas of you know prioritizing people
because of their race or their sex or
their sexuality once those things are
pushed to the Forefront then all the
issues of Merit get inevitably just
pushed to the back and that just has a
trickle down effect on every aspect of
society every job every recruitment
process you're a uh if I can say so I
mean you're an amazing example of Merit
in your own life uh you escaped to forc
marriage went to the Netherlands learned
Dutch which isn't easy became a member
of the Dutch Parliament and built a
career for yourself in Europe and then
America um why is it though that this
this sort of merit-based uh uh system
why do you think it's become so
unpopular because surely as you say it's
it's it's it's the best chance anyone
has it's not unpopular but this is a
very loud minority that want to get a
ahead only for themselves and then they
are claiming they speak for All Blacks
for all women for all uh you know gender
identity minorities they don't speak for
any of these minorities they do this so
that they can get ahead Ibrahim excis
speaks for himself Claudine gay speaks
for herself she doesn't speak for me I
think it's very important Douglas to
note that there are disparities in our
societies there are large groups of
people who are left behind and it's
extremely important to tackle that and
the way to do it and the way to lift up
the people who are left behind is to
make them a part of the values that make
us come ahead the values of hard work
the values of community the values of
commitment of responsibility of getting
up in the morning of lifting yourself up
up by your bootstraps that I think is
what for me America is all about and we
can do that without degrading the
standards of what has lifted up everyone
out of poverty and this is what these
people are doing and I think it's time
that they're exposed and called out and
it's and this is just the beginning
let's get down to where the rot is I
could agree what but finally let me just
ask you I mean this seems to have come
about because of an idea that
everything's a zero sum game you know if
for instance if if women are going to be
advanced in Society men have to be
punished you know if if there's going to
be more visibility of gay people you've
got to punish straight people and
degrade straight people and that if if
you're going to make more opportunities
or not even more opportunities just put
people in positions of of more
prominence in American society or
British Society you've got to sort of
beat up on white people a bit and all
the Studies have shown in recent years
in America and in Britain there was one
again just a couple of years ago that
this means among other things that you
have the Left Behind of white men young
white men who nobody's speaking up for
absolutely you hear that all the time
you don't want black men to um move
ahead and leave white young men behind
you want everyone to advance and I think
in order to do this we have to be really
honest about the Frameworks that we have
the framework of equal opportunity not
Equity as they call it which is the e in
the Dei which is about equal outcomes
and we know where equal outcomes we know
where hardcore socialism and hardcore
communism we know where they lead they
lead to more disparity more Division and
they lead to the gulags and that's what
these people are all about and I think
it is I'm just really grateful that the
conversation has now begun and that we
can a address disparities and fight
racism fight misogyny um stand up for
people with gender dysphoria H and not
have their suffering used against them
so that people like these crazy
transgender activists can get ahead um
and I think Douglas I mean Happy New
Year I think we are starting the new
year off on a good on a good in a good
place well I agree but who' have thought
that Harvard was a place which Dei went
to die thank you very much Ayan her Ali
you're welcome back
anytime and next tonight on
uncensored as we hurtle towards a UK
election this year the conservative
party Deputy chairman Lee Anderson says
the Reform Party poses a bigger threat
to the Tories than labor is he right
we'll debate with the pack right after
the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about toour today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it's hard to
know whether it's a f or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from Gram was president of the
Cambridge unit which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan you have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's about Twitter you sons of can
you please reinstate my account thank
you this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik to problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlled
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your question are you prepared to
call h a terror group is it possible to
have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV
welcome back to uncensored I'm delighted
to be joined with my pack of talk TV
contributors Esther kru and Paul lone
Adrian and they're joined tonight by the
mirrors associate editor Kevin Maguire
now there's quite a bit to cover with
you I first of all I wanted to ask you
this comment by Lee Anderson the Tory MP
let's start with you Kevin he says that
the reform UK which some people might
not have heard of presents a bigger risk
to the the conservatives than the labor
party at the next election do you agree
no but he's under threaten his own seat
in Ashfield where he fears you the
Reform Party was the brexit party was
ukip right-wing party will take votes
and he will lose his seat there's no
there's no doubt the right of British
politics is fracturing between the
conservatives and reform and that will
help labor but no labor is a bigger
threat Karm is a bigger Threat by the
way Lee Anderson also said that
reformers he didn't say they're a bigger
threat to the conservative party he also
said they're a bigger threat to the
country at the moment than the labor
party and he also said he% of them yeah
I think we're underestimate we're
talking about you know very safe blue
seats potentially swinging reform which
is you know there's Merit there but
we're also underestimating red wall
seats that did vote for brexit that have
traditionally voted for restricting
immigration that have you know voted
against the exis of globalization they
go they probably also go reform I
wouldn't that wouldn't surprise me
because the thing is as well fail
because the thing is hold on they they
would be ideologically less inclined to
go towards labor they see them e either
as the same as the Tories or even worse
I mean if you think about it if you're a
traditional workingclass voter from the
north what do you have in common with
any of the two big parties at least
reform is talking to them that's the
difference well as I said I I I think
actually this step back to label for a
lot of the red ball voters we we
probably would see that coming I think
they've been so let down by brexit um I
think they'll understand that reform
won't be able to give them what they
probably want H and what this country
needs actually is stability what this
country needs is is but if we just look
at it electorally yeah right reform when
it was the brexit party didn't stand in
conservative seats it's a thater right
right-wing party now if it's going to
stand in conservative seats as well as
labor seats this time which it will then
it is going to be a threat to the
conservatives it will fracture that
right-wing vote and that will be good
for K St just straight El the Bigg
concern is we not knowing as much about
reforms policy positions as the other
parties that's the issue because we know
reforms you know political history has
been mainly focused on brexit where do
they stand on other issues like social
Poli when when they get exctly you can't
just stand up and keep talking about
brexit next election I mean I mean you
know eight years of it lenting the
people who talk about brexit now tend to
be remainers they're the ones who Define
themselves they feel they lost it's a
it's proved to be a disaster while a lot
of people who voted for brexit like to
avoid it now because it hasn't turned
out the way it was promised to voters
but they're a very anti-migrant party
reform um I think I think that's where
they will hit it hard now you think that
has any effect in the labor heartlands
only a little I think I think you got to
be more you got to be more than that and
it feels that is their only real selling
point at if you look at Coastal
communities that have demographic
demographically shifted quite radically
like Norwich and all these areas you can
actually see the sway of of Reform my
issue is I don't know where they stand
on anything else education you know
housing social policy infrastructure all
of these things you know we can't have
one party that says something that we
like and think oh they're going to say
yeah yeah abolutely and we we do deserve
to know uh let me take you on to another
subject uh junior doctors in England are
preparing to Stage the longest strike in
NHS history with Medics due to walk out
for six days in the escalation of the r
it's starting today I mean where do you
stand on this let's start with you again
Kevin um I mean it seems to me you know
there there today people have been
called to be told that their
appointments that operations have been
cancelled heart operations life- saving
operations of a lot of people who do you
have sympathy with here oh I've got huge
sympathy with patients but any
industrial dispute and I've covered
industrial disputes going back to the
late uh 80s it takes two sides to talk
and both sides the the government is
saying it won't uh talk while strikes
are going on well it's got to swallow
its pride and talk and the and the
doctors have to go into those talks we
talk about Junior doctors they are 40%
of the doctors in the NHS this is in
England Scotland settled uh Wales there
may be disputes later and there's some
ban going on in Northern I but
predominantly an an English problem
where the conservative government has
handled uh relations in the NHS terribly
which is why you had the nurses strikes
and you had the consultant they are ask
they are asking just quick they are
asking the junior doctors you say 40% of
the workforce the NHS which is the fifth
largest employer in the entire world uh
they are asking for a
35% pay rise now I think a lot of people
watching will think 35% pay rise is
quite chunky the thing the key the key
lines with public opinion because that's
when you you'll know whether the strikes
will are likely to be successful so
we've known that since strikes have
begun over the last couple of years that
the strikes that have received the most
public support have been nurses strikes
now they've settled right because after
Co they only got a two they only offered
a 2% pay rise and the public were
rightly outraged and then at the bottom
of that is University lecturers because
they are pumping out useless students
and making our lives hell you cannot
keep this going and expect the public to
have sympathy with you when you're
asking for 35% pay rise because that is
impossible no one not even the private
sector gets but Esther it's a lot more
complicated than that we know that
they're that that they're asking for 35%
but they're what they're also saying is
don't give us 35% today we we understand
that you can't give it to us today but
in terms of making up our pay that is
what that figure would what other
employer if you said if you said I want
a 35% pay increase you don't have to
give it to me right away but you have to
give it to me quite soon I mean dougas
that 35% is going back to 2008 so a 15E
period they took a bigger hit that the
value of their earnings dropped more
than ambulance Crews more than NHS
workers nurs of course inflation came in
as well and it's now it's actually now
down to 26% the Govern the government
gave them 88.8% they settling the strike
their frustration is with their Union as
opposed to the government because we've
had successive governments since 2008
and I think the the bigger Point here is
when you compare it to other countries
like Australia like the US like Canada
all these countries saying they earn
significantly less they make 20% of
their in goes towards their pension as
well so they have a very good package
government the government are using this
as a tactic as a ploy if they wanted to
talk to the junior doctors they could do
they did with other doctors they did
with the bars they just refusing they
what they want to do is they want the
NHS to be run down we are watching the
demise of the NHS we need to support the
doctors to we are always told that we're
facing the demise of the NHS and um
we've got a particularly incompetent
government when it comes to organizing
maybe maybe the has we also quite
regularly have very incompetent
governments Kevin so uh that's not an
excuse either I want to bring you on to
the really crucial issue of the day
which is of course darts um Luke luk
Luke ller began his PDC World darts
Championship debut hoping simply to win
one game but now the 16-year-old
Sensation will face Luke humph on
Wednesday evening tonight in what is
anticipated to be the most watched final
in the tournament's 31 year history uh
Luke is 16 uh we've got a photo I think
somewhere here uh yep there you go
there's a 16-year-old Luke I don't
believe uh I uh I still find that kind
of amazing um we've got though by way of
comparison it's very important to
everyone viewing they can see another
16y old here's a here's a 16-year-old uh
I think his Pier
here 16 no he wasn't more like six well
I I wouldn't like to see I wouldn't like
to see the two of them in a title F I
tell you that I think I know who my
money would be on hang on it's worse
it's worse hang on we've got a young
Kevin oh God the hair Kevin Kevin Kevin
come on explain yourself my dad used to
call that girl's hair I
know very long black hair back there
horrifying this you I have PTSD looking
hang on you exactly the same you look
exactly the same that's horrify you not
aged I was I was asked to produce a
photograph of myself at 16 and I said
bur them all so there was no chance at
all anyway thank you very much to all of
you in the pack it's been great to have
you all here in London up next on
uncensored I'll be talking to one of the
world's most popular personal growth
gurus Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast about whether New Year
New You resolutions are all a load of
old nonsense that's after the
[Music]
break
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online run
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well Tred
most dog owners will tell you a dog can
turn do you know what I love about to
today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tories love a SC you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what do we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for liit if you're walking
towards me and you're vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in 3 years hundreds and hundreds of mice
in a box which he walks into a branch of
McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse man MC man
he should be easy enough to catch this
guy should I mean he's got house full of
Bice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
fil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party hi
off kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes course I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible of a rational I've asked you
two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back to
uncensored so how are you doing with
your New Year's resolutions do you even
make any or are they broken already well
fear not because my next guest is the
king of self-improvement having built an
online community of over 1 and a half
million subscribers who follow follow
his talks and debates on Modern wisdom
I'm delighted to welcome all the way
over from Austin the podcaster and
YouTuber Chris
Williamson thanks so much for being with
us
Chris I appreciate you thank you for
having me the roles are reversed for
once I know it's my turn to interrogate
you uh now look I want to ask you first
of all just on a lightish note uh New
Year's resolutions do you do them I do
yeah I'm a big fan of New Year's
resolutions and I have been for a while
and what are they
uh stop using my phone so much go to bed
on time don't eat as much sugar it's the
basic things that everybody else does
the basic ones are the ones that are
most important uh what about you have
you got any New Year's resolutions I'm
trying to give up dry January but anyway
um uh yeah the I don't know I mean I I I
always break them um but but there is
something to to be said for the sort of
reset isn't there there all January
reset I mean Christmas is a kind of
gluttonous season probably always was
but yeah resetting your body for
instance the best time to take a break
from drinking is when you've got a
massive hangover and I think the best
time to take a break from being a
gluttonous pig is straight after you've
just been one for a while but I
understand why people have got questions
around new year new me it's become a bit
of a metameme and by the end of January
about 80% of people have already given
up on their resolutions we're on the
third of January now so maybe people
have already started to peel off and
then only 8% of people actually achieved
their new year resolution so I
understand why people have skepticism
around it is this something which is
even useful there was a Tik Tock
psychoanalyst and clinical social worker
who said that she had disdain for
Resolutions on January the 1st because
they're an unrealistic fantasy that will
inevitably make you feel like a failure
now if we have lost the ability to be
sufficiently brave to be able to take on
eating less sugar or going to bed on
time I worry for the conviction that we
have in other areas of our life as well
yeah quite well said I um I wanted you
know tell us a little bit about yourself
Chris because you uh you've had an
extraordinary journey in your career you
you started off as you say as a
self-declared ex-professional party boy
uh you now have this amazing following
online add off um you you speak among
other things to a lot of I think I'm
right in saying so to a lot of young uh
people and it seems to me that one of
the reasons for that is that there very
few people in our society who can give
kind of guidance there's a lot of lost
young people in our society in Britain
America in the west and and they're
looking for not just sort of you know
dietry advice but they're looking for
they're looking for sort of mental
nurture and and perhaps even sort of
Life nurturing they want to do something
with their lives and and nobody's giving
them any
advice well as you have written about
the grand narratives that we relied on
for a very long time many of them have
collapse we find ourselves in a world
which is hopelessly incompatible and
unmatched to the even evolutionary place
that we found ourselves in 100,000 years
ago and people quite rightly are looking
for okay so what does this mean I have
all of this freedom I have all of this
time I have all of this opportunity and
optionality in front of me and between
all of these different things where
should I go it's confusing there's this
great idea called the Paradox of Choice
by Barry Schwarz so if you were to go
back 50 years and you were to go and buy
a pair of jeans you would go into the
store and there would be one type of
jeans in a couple of different waist
sizes and you would walk out and maybe
they weren't the perfect par of jeans
that you wanted but you felt satisfied
with your decision because what else
could you have chosen now you're going
to buy a pair of jeans and do you want
boot cut or skinny or stretch do you
want them to be bleached you want them
to be gray do you want them to be
cropped any decision that you make with
a suboptimal pair of genes is now no
longer because of constraints from the
environment it's because of you it's
because of your inability to make an
appropriate decision and this is where a
multiplicity of options sounds like it
would be great it would open up so many
different avenues for people means you
can choose exactly what you want the
pair of genes in a lifestyle perspective
but look at what actually happens people
end up feeling trapped paralysis of
analysis and they feel less satisfied
with the decisions that they make so
more options aren't always the solution
and quite rightly people look for
guidance to help them navigate through
whatever this new terrain is when people
ask you uh what the big things were in
your life that uh made you sort of you
know I'm not saying your life was in
disorder but to get your life in order
to to get it to the place you are now a
huge following very successful just
finished a major tour what what do you
see as being the turning points in your
own
life so
I for most of my 20s was largely an
adult infant and I think a lot of young
guys might be able to resonate with that
that I was succeeding in a way that
maybe people in the UK would consider
success with a lot of freedom and being
able to party and go out with your
friends and stuff but it wasn't
fulfilling me existentially and that me
had to make some changes some of the
biggest ones were sleeping with my phone
outside of my bedroom I found that I was
chipping away at my sleep every single
night losing 30 minutes or an hour and
if I couldn't sleep I could roll over
and use it and people say but I I use my
phone for my alarm clock whatever will I
do dude radio alarm clocks have been
around for like a thousand years just go
and get yourself a radio alarm clock uh
another massive change that I made was I
went sober for six months twice and then
I went sober for a thousand days I
didn't drink that much I wasn't a
massive drinker but I found that it
really focused my time and my attention
and my consistency and basically getting
a hangover is like electing to make
yourself ill very chronically for about
24 or 36 hours depending on how old you
are and that helped helped me to have
more consistency time energy attention
to spend on things that I care about so
yeah I mean if people were able to do
phone outside of bedroom and no alcohol
for January I think that by the end of
it they will find them eles in a much
better place you've interviewed uh on
your podcast some of the biggest brains
on the planet I'm not going to name any
names but uh you've been on three times
I wasn't raising that but uh but what
genuinely what what do you think the
most important things are that you've
learned from people what do you mean
with the things that have really just
stuck with
you there's no such thing as success
without consistency no matter what it is
that you want to do whether it's build a
business lose weight be rich richer
become a better parent learn a
skill being consistent won't guarantee
success but not being consistent will
guarantee that you won't be successful
so this push and pull that people go
through this concern that they have
about starting again at all it's the
beginning of the year why should I you
know 80% of New Year's resolutions are
already given up by the end of January
what's even the point of me beginning to
do this thing well because your stick to
it muscle is something that can be
trained and over time yes this year
maybe you only do make it to February
but next year maybe you make it to March
and the year after that maybe you make
it to May and that is way better than
just admitting defeat but yeah for me
consistency is the one thing that all of
the high Achievers I've spoken to have
got but I I am waiting I am looking
forward to the Douglas Murray fitness
plan to come out eventually which I've
been promised at some point will be
dropping and every new year I I look for
it and it's not here that's a long
stretch ambition for a lot of people uh
but but what what role does money play
in happiness do you think uh uh many
people spend their whole lives pursuing
it uh many people end up not doing what
they wanted to do with their lives
because they're chasing to be richer or
chasing for a pay increase what role do
you think money does actually make
people
happy I think that being rich might not
guarantee happiness but being poor is
probably a pretty good predictor of
being miserable that there are certain
material circumstances which are going
to be imposed on you like being in
poverty is such a huge stressor for
people you get trapped because all of
your time is spent trying to deal with
the problem of poverty or being poor and
that means that you don't have any time
to do anything else which traps you in
poverty this is why you get to those who
have more more will be given and to
those who have less less more will be
taken that's why that Dynamic occurs I
think that people should Endeavor to get
themselves to be comfortable I do think
that that's important and it's an
uncomfortable ground truth of reality
but once you've got the spacing more and
more and more money doesn't guarantee
that you're going to be happy I know a
lot of people that are super rich and
way more miserable than my friends who
aren't now I've got to ask you one final
question whilst I have you you sent out
a tweet today about a a quite
appallingly uh graphic type of personal
injury which the male of the species can
apparently suffer particularly during
the Christmas period we're all safely
out of that now uh but can I just ask
you on that subject sex love where does
that fit in I thought you were going to
ask me about that very specific yeah I
did I can't actually go into the details
because this is a the family show good
I'm I'm glad I I think that there is a
current anti- relationship culture I
think that men and women are
increasingly seeing each others as
adversaries as enemies and they're not
they're collaborators they should and do
work very well together and I think that
you don't need a relationship to live a
happy life but it definitely helps and
not prioritizing it is a uh high-risk
strategy and
sex sex as much of it as possible
ideally as much as
possible well you know when you're not
on PS Morgan Live hosted
by but but as you know but presumably
just quickly I mean I mean uh you also
mean I mean sort of playing the game I
think a lot of you know a lot of
evidence shows isn't necessarily the way
to happiness no of course of course not
of course you don't need to have as much
as possible but I do think there's some
interesting studies that have been come
out that have been released that
say the amount of sex that you want to
have is round about satisfaction and
then a little bit more than the friends
that are around you if you are having a
little bit less sex than the friends
that are around you it seems like you
can quite highly predict whether someone
will be dissatisfied with their sex life
so perhaps become friends with a bunch
of priests or Unix and then you'll feel
satisfied with your sex life no matter
how much you're having well Chris thank
you for joining us and I certainly hope
very much that you never suffer that
particular personal Christmas injury you
told us all about which is going to
haunt me for the rest of the year thank
you Chris Williamson now that's it for
me tonight whatever you're up to make
sure it's
uncensored good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this Hammer
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming round the tracks
with sella bravman she's head up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police are pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear and Al in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a f or a tragedy talk TB
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking liit if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan you have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy should he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz Phil